I am about to tell you sounds crazy and
you have to listen to me your very lives
depend on it
what day is it for you
Judgment Day you just came in with the
fresh recruits
new day people
destiny call haven't you've been one of
these before happy
they see how do i turn the 51 weapon
come find me when you wake up it's a new
day people
who said you could talk to me you did
tomorrow at the beach we made
you do know it's happening to me we are
fighting an organism
they have the power to race that the day
and now so to you
the new gay people
how do I control it
every day I'm not even trained for
combat
your legs broken No I keep sucking on my
coke
then we better start over
I can't do this I'm not a soldier
you're a weapon every time you die you
get smarter
and you want to make sure that we can
win
as far as you ever make it what does it
matter what happens to me
I wish I didn't know you but I do
I know way coming
and waiting for us because we've been
here before
where's your helmet
how many times have we been here
how many times
for me it's been an eternity
what is vanity
you